hey there welcome to another clueless
gamer today we are playing Gears of War
4 which comes out October 11th on Xbox
one this is one of the most intense
brutal violent and disturbing games out
there so I wanted to bring someone in
who could help mellow out the vibe a
little bit wiz khalifa played this game
before I'm terrible at video games I'm
pretty good at candy crush you know I
like anything that has a fruit in it
like a strawberry or a fruit ninja fruit
ninja so I can see why vegetables are
good for you yeah well it into a really
good message from Wiz a vegetable or a
show yeah guessing that's these are my
vegetables yeah yeah would you have a
hype man something like it but it ain't
what you wanna do what if you're up
there and you're rapping and yeah you
got it going another hike man
yeah and I'm there and I'm going that's
right laying it down with style see the
real corker from where here we go now
not too loud everyone settle down I was
skinny
and then you walked into the room and
we've met before but if you weren't one
of the skinniest guys I'm worried about
you will ya are you eating enough well
I'm a vegetarian good it looks good
how can you smell anything other than
like this here I actually rode you with
anyone
all right I'm not gonna light it up
right now but maybe I'll just have it
hanging out of my lip yeah so Gears of
War 4 it basically takes place on this
planet Sara where humanity is fighting
against these the Locust Horde which is
this underground reptilian reptilian
humanoid creatures and humanity kind of
mines the stuff called the emulsion
which is basically liquid yellow energy
which also mutates the locusts into
thing called the lambent 13 ghost on
this image pause for a second I'm gonna
need the light up yes so the lambent
hate both humanity and the locust and
Marcus Fenix our hero along with his
delta numbers i detonate this emulsion
counterman so that is kind of a bummer
like quick questions we need to know
this to play the game because we're just
gonna walk around shoot people right
yeah you just you're fired
get out take it easy wizard oh so I
thought you were supposed to be mellow
you just described me 24/7
where's I got you back don't worry
where's the grenade I'm over here
waddling around with my guns big robot
suit yeah
that means we're superior you notice
that the leaves have turned it must be
fall
did I shoot you in the back of the head
oh my god
look at that let's go big boy Alysha
he will not die it's very hard to his
launch I told you I never had to rip a
robotic Tyrannosaurus Rex his head off
before the Sun told me that if that's
what I wanted to do that's how I
should've died
[Laughter]
oh that's cool
like that it looks like a Bob Ross
painting oh I died you the tree I hit
the tree
we was hitting the tree and then you hit
the tree I've had my entire life
oh yeah baby that's great that was
fantastic
that was fantastic
realize the fire department has been
here six times they keep why they come
here years of war for October 11th it
drops on Xbox one
hey I just played Gears of War 4 with
Wiz Khalifa we had a blast if you want
to check out more clueless gamers just
click here to subscribe see that wigs
can you point that out Wiz can actually
see it even though we're gonna put it on
later in editing which is so high he can
see it now